yeah anyone welcome to this video let's
get going and see what happens I have a
couple of windows open because it's
extremely hot and I need some fresh air
so I hope any potential outside noises
are not too irritating but otherwise I
would simply I don't know meltdown here
okay
it's my rating so bad I'm not really
getting anywhere him okay
very solid opening I wanted to play the
Queens gambit accepted but it didn't
work out how Paul and some day waited
with any sea form and here we have we
are fairly standard kind of position
usually you get this from ready is love
hybrid sandwiches probably what this is
called I should have put the bishop
maybe on e7 yeah now with hindsight I
probably would have made quite a bit of
sense but okay I mean he's not not
really testing me here all that much at
least that's what I think
okay Queen a5 is a useful temper and I'm
attacking I'm actually double attacking
maybe I can take a two even it's greedy
okay this is a way to cover things Queen
a - there's UK one now I can try to pile
up a bit on d4
what he did here which i think is not so
great is to trade a bit too much and
this gives me better opportunities to
put pressure on the pole
like now with the nanites traded that is
much easier to double against the
default point for example if you have a
night only five never doubling against
this okay Queen to b6 was mostly to have
an additional attacker I mean like
everything now is on the pond even
though I move like b5 is certainly part
of my my agenda yeah
here for example if I take on d4 there's
going to be c5 and I'm losing material
this is not bad though here again double
attacking a3 is not hanging to Trey okay
one but I would this this was my idea
I wanted to play b5 yeah yeah still
let's do it
okay yeah that it's the easiest option
taking I thought was a bit tough um and
not easy I mean I'm not winning why do
you think you're just like Nike now this
is easiest to let's say for me to handle
I just double triple quadruple whatever
against you for it's got many many porns
on dark squares yeah if five is already
a move I just wonder if it's best or if
I'm releasing things too early I can
still improve further if I go if I live
now how is he handling I think I'm
winning in this pawn right if he takes
these three Hanks and now my queen is
actually ready to play Queen d8 if
necessary this is a standoff here on the
default funny if it takes h5 I have Edie
for air winning stuff attacking the
Queen attacking the bishop oops didn't
meant to do that
and then not many noises from outside
unfortunately yeah so take it yeah I
guess it's kind of a model almost ideal
kind of strategy or an ideal display of
blacks strategy in this kind of these
kind of situations
okay rupee eight I probably have to do
this just not exactly great news
there is a yeah not much else I cannot
allow who creates them yeah it's still
not so easy if he takes on d4 we're so
dealing with the self pin that you have
to somehow untangle with white I'm not
quite sure how this should work yeah
that is the other option but I mean here
yeah I'm better just no wait I have this
okay let's start trying to figure this
out Bishop we have six that first looks
like it wins it does not I think you two
look before threatening you create and I
cannot take the bishop which is a bit of
a shame mm if I take I'm going to be
better if I just take it I mean just I
have the better a better structure in
regards to the bishop but
it's a bit of a pain yeah that's it
Bishop f6 it's not winning okay okay I
can check here this is not doing much
it's however really good Square for the
Queen so let's do it and what now I move
the bishop is going to have to invest
the tempo I don't really have a good
square down King of King f8 as Bishop
take the g7 it's not really not really
great
no that's it is quite Josh I need to
activate this Bishop somehow maybe if I
am I know it's not Josh what are you
doing there I have an extra king in this
ending I mean I'm not sure them winning
but I'm definitely no better yeah I
don't have a good ship squared okay
Bishop h6 is good very good
in fact I would you see where does he
put his we should now f4 maybe is that
this idea f4 f5 I need to stop that
[Music]
should that's a good move
got that no sorry it's this oh it's a
bit sad have to basically decline
rematch I should hope we should be seven
maybe I'm with hindsight or B should be
for the engine suggests not a bad move
yeah okay this is it's not a big problem
but it would have been more precise
okay Queen to Knight f6 and here you
should not trade 92 for example I know
it looks maybe I would counterintuitive
to some to retreat but this is the most
active move it just avoids the trades
and then you can try to expand with your
pawns and here I'm immediately okay as
confirmed by the engine now the dynamic
possibilities have been greatly reduced
and I can put put pressure on their porn
I think I'm now happy 5 them that's
something that the engine now points out
I played it later it's part of this
position type but probably my timing
wasn't wasn't the best it's okay I mean
engine confirms basically my play I was
expecting him to take to be honest I
thought that would give a bit more
chances like he and I will have to take
with the Queen as this is probably two
draws I thought maybe not I mean I saw
that I'm winning a pawn but I felt it
probably to draw us diffic very
difficult like here if he triples on
there
it's very difficult to make any headway
I recently I recently saw a game of that
type from one of my students it's no way
forward even a pawn down and c5 is very
easy now for me to handle I can
basically triple on that pawn and play
e5 at the opportune moment
Quincy aids and now e5 yeah I think I'm
quite happy a plate is okay I think now
the conversion stage I didn't do all
that well then okay the engine just
gives king of a jam yeah it's good it's
just a good move I should not have
returned the pawn
yeah here I actually cannot do all that
much it is okay the engine here zero
point something for white is a bit of a
joke but now it goes down to zero
yeah I think this is a really bad idea
that loses him it really showed it I'm
claiming with an extra King but I did
not play well from here g6 is fine and
King d3 years valence very stats very
strong obviously King the 3m and then
Bishop h6 that keeps the King a totally
passive I mean ever witnessed this stuff
here anyway it's really not much that
they can do and it's almost looks fun
this Bishop he has no squares and like
King f4 has a chick something like that
is a pretty terrible suit swung has to
go back and then every should not two
wins after the trade just going to go
into win and here this is probably still
a women as the engine confirms but
tricky
and I'm very certain I spoil it at some
point
Bishop a3 I think we should be to g4
Bishop c3 Bishop a3 is supposed to my
better
and now g5 I felt lost yeah yeah that
lost a 4mm and engines has - 1.4 so what
is the line there I think I probably
would have taken G for this f5 okay
would have done that with the time
ticking down
f5 --tags --tags --tags --tags can see
for while you have to do all this in the
first place and it's not so easy
[Music]
he takes f6 that's probably a win not
very relevant practically I have to play
this and anything can happen I mean okay
Blake should lose but you know what I
mean
like table base probably claims the
black women almost not certain I think
still have to play it and after g5 I
think we should be a one-take age 4 is a
draw I actually thought that was a
clever move ok it's not a clever move
because ok this seems to Winston okay at
least that King before the was in plug
him king f4 was totally lost that was
the game f-4s the engine suggestion Age
3 back only three winning here right am
I not
v TX g 6f for g7f phage - mom
check it's not it's not clear yes no way
to win this pawn and I'm probably
getting those okay with this time range
the end games are always going to be a
bit shaky just cannot just cannot play
perfectly your white design yeah thanks
a lot for watching